there's also a new rideshare scam to
tell you about it's going to make your
stomach turn even the title or the name
of it
brian's about to say it it's called
vomit fraud it happens when an uber or
lyft driver stages throw up in their car
after a ride all in order to charge
their passenger a high fee
a man reached out to us here at 8 news
now saying this happened to him kate
houston talked to him live near the
strip with steps to take if this happens
to you kate this is just an odd one
yes this is bizarre and between now and
new year's eve there's going to be
thousands of people taking ride shares
up and down the las vegas strip but that
man i spoke to says that passengers need
to take some extra steps before they get
into the car to protect themselves and
protect their wallet
ryan pinto took a 10-minute lift ride
from his hotel to the private aviation
side of the airport he says an hour
after he was dropped off he received an
80 damage fee which is the third highest
damage tier for throw up pinto assumed
it may have been the passenger after him
but once he saw these photos taken by
the driver he knew it was a scam right
away i told them you know i've got five
stars i've got over 200 rides i've never
thrown up in someone's car
and i'm showing up to work they can see
it's a 10-minute drive i'm showing up to
the airport to fly an airplane obviously
i'm not sick or intoxicated i reached
out to lyft about disputing charges like
this a representative said they take
these seriously and if riders believe
there was an error they should reach out
to lyft support directly according to
the lyft website passengers will be
notified about damage fees over email or
on the ride history tab on the lyft app
passengers can reply directly to the
follow-up email
and while lyft will be looking into
pinto's incident directly he says that
the disputing process was frustrating
because he was really only able to speak
to somebody over messenger instead of on
the phone and going forward he
recommends passengers use their phone to
take photos or video of the drive
beforehand and afterwards reporting live
near the strip kate houston live local
now